godzilla 2019 weighed 99
634 tons which is only 366 tons
shy of a hundred thousand tons which
would put him out of this list
but nevertheless there are 9 of these
monsters that have crossed the threshold
and will be showcased accordingly in
ascending order of weight
we have done an earlier video about the
largest and heaviest villains of
godzilla
be sure to check that out too and this
one will include a couple of kaiju that
weren't on the list
as well as proper revisions of a couple
more kaiju
on how heavy they actually are so enjoy
this video on the nine godzilla monsters
that are
over 100 000 tons on the number nine
spot we have
geyser ghidorah originally appearing as
monster x it was a bipedal creature with
an
exoskeleton-like armored skin it
possesses two small
half skulls on shoulders and a long
black fog tail
monster x has red eyes a skeletal face
and long spikes on the top of his head
in this form it was only 60 000 tons but
later in the movie godzilla final wars
monster x evolved into geyser ghidorah
which was its true form
in this he was quadruped with three
heads on three long armored necks
with a couple of wings on his back and
two tails in this form he was 460 feet
tall
and a hundred thousand tons number eight
godzilla earth
this godzilla looks like it has an
exposed musculature over its entire body
in a manner similar to the 2016 godzilla
and it also resembles a bit to the 2014
godzilla as well
however this godzilla deviates from
looking like pure muscle
and bears more of a likeness towards the
roots of plants with moss-like details
being prevalent on its feet as well it
was in fact a planned kaiju that mutated
over time
and was the epitome of evolution and
natural selection
this incarnation was the biggest
godzilla to ever appear in the big
screen
easily over one thousand feet tall but
surprisingly
only one hundred thousand tons number
seven methuselah
this monster also dubbed as titanos
methuselah is a giant animal planned
rock hybrid daikaiju created for kotm
methuselah is a quadruped titan with a
forest growing on its rocky and
mountainous back
with whitish eyes and a mouth with large
razor sharp teeth
he also has large horns growing down
from the top of his head
that girl inwards his four limbs are
clawed while his high limbs are hoofed
methuselah also has a reptilian tail
officially
its height is 322 feet tall at the
shoulder
but its weight is as estimated by
die-hard fans
puts him at around 124 000 tons
number 6 the muto prime this one also
known as titanos jinshin mushi
or simply jinshin moshi was a gigantic
parasitic kaiju that evolved perfectly
to kill
and lay eggs on godzilla's species the
muta prime is near identical in
appearance to a regular female muto
except that it was taller
at around 350 feet tall and his body was
clad in hard
armor the back had numerous spikes and
spires on it
and its volumes were enormous orange in
color and could induce earthquakes
muta prime was said to be 50 heavier
than godzilla
and since the g-man was 90 000 tons this
would put prime
at 135 000 tons number five
monster zero like most of his past
incarnations
ghidorah is much larger than godzilla
ghidorah's wings
here are much larger and more bat like
in appearance than most incarnations
ghidorah is an extremely malevolent
entity which is supported by the skulls
depicted
surrounding him in a cave painting and
the fact that the ancient cultures
barely wrote anything about him
as they wanted him to be forgotten it
still had three long necks
and dragon heads and two tails and a
golden body
it was 521 feet tall with a wingspan of
over one thousand feet
and weighed 141 000 056 tons
number four super mecha godzilla like
its shower counterpart
this mechagodzilla was constructed
specifically to destroy godzilla
however this time it was built by the
human military organization geforce
in order to defend japan from godzilla
constructed using component salvage from
mecca king ghidorah
it was based on the appearance of
godzilla himself but it is mechanical
and metal in nature
mechagodzilla's body is composed of a
shiny silver metal and his eyes are
orange in color
it was 400 feet tall and weighed more
than 150 000 tons
as super mecha godzilla when combined
with garuda
number three moguera constructed by the
g-force after the destruction of mecca
godzilla
moguera was built to do what its
predecessor had come
so close to doing destroy godzilla
mogura's first action came not against
godzilla but a crystalline anomaly
that was cited approaching earth which
later became space godzilla
although intended to kill the g-man it
ended up fighting alongside godzilla
against space godzilla
and even though the battle was won
muguera was destroyed
this was the largest maker in the
godzilla universe standing 400 feet tall
and 160 000 tons number two biollante
in the beginning biolanter was a giant
rose with a set of jaws inside her butt
and her tendrils as well as long vines
it was merely a heavily mutated plan
and was an exponentially large
semi-sentient rose
in her second form however the godzilla
genes took over and biollante's body
became
an abomination of biological science
biollante's second form
had a head similar to that of a mososaur
but with tusks
and it had a large number of vines and
tendrils biolanter was always thought to
be the biggest monster that godzilla had
faced
standing at 400 feet tall and weighing
200 000 tons
number one bagan this is an ancient
super kaiju who made its official debut
not in the movies
but in the 1993 godzilla game super
godzilla
while bagan had never made an official
on-screen appearance
he is particularly well known for his
numerous plan but ultimately
scrap film roles the first proposed
appearance of bagan
was resurrection of godzilla and then
godzilla vs bagan
but were cancelled he looks like a
three-horned carnivorous dinosaur kaiju
with a massive bony exoskeleton
he was stated to be more than 490 feet
tall and would weigh around 280
000 tons putting him at a number one
spot and so with that we come to the end
of this video
on the heaviest kaiju the ones over 100
000 tons
wish there were more and if you know
please put them down in the comments
section
anyways take care fam do hit that like
subscribe button
and also the notification bell for
regular updates